ist bei uns SPD Generalsekretär toller
Tag für euch bei der SPD natürlich wir
haben vorhin Armin Laschet gehört und
ich möchte Ihnen einen kurzen Satz
Vorlesen den er gesagt hat und so hat
gesagt keine Partei kann aus diesem
klaren Ergebnis einen Regierungsauftrag
ableiten auch nicht die SPD er wollte
natürlich sagen kann aus diesem Ergebnis
einen klaren
Regierungsauftrag ableiten und hat sich
da selbst bloßgestellt auch nicht die
SPD
ja ich weiß gar nicht wie man das noch
kommentieren soll aber Armin Laschet
schafft es ja sogar sich am Wahltag zu
blamieren wenn er die Stimmen abgibt und
alles was wir jetzt gerade erleben zeigt
ja dass da ein Spitzenkandidat dann
kannst da Kandidat außer Rand und Band
ist das dass er jetzt einfach versucht
seine Macht zu retten und dass die Union
ihm ziemlich egal ist kriegt das bei mir
im Wahlkreis an der Basis mit wo alle
jetzt eine ehrliche Aufarbeitung dieses
Ergebnis ist fordern aber überhaupt
nicht damit einverstanden sind das Armin
Laschet jetzt der Meinung ist ihr könnte
irgendwie Kanzler werden und da muss man
ja wirklich sagen das Ergebnis gestern
war eindeutig die SPD hat sich von Platz
3 auf Platz 1 gekämpft wenn ich die
persönlichen Vergleiche zwischen Laschet
und Scholz hier die sind auch eindeutig
wir sind die stärkste Partei wir haben
gestern Abend gewonnen und wir wollen
jetzt gucken dass wir schnell eine
Regierung mit FDP und Grün auf den Weg
bringen er hat ja Entschuldigung Paul
eins möchte ich gerne wissen er hat ja
öffentlich nie wie es sich eigentlich
unter Demokraten gehört zum Wahlsieg
gratuliert hat er Olaf Scholz mal eine
SMS geschickt oder sowas und auf also
nach Informationen hat Armin Laschet das
nicht getan das ist etwas was ich so
auch in der Tat wie sie sagen dass ich
kenne ich so dass man sich gratuliert
also derjenige der vorne ist dem sagt
man mal gut gemacht herzlichen
Glückwunsch das ist nicht passiert und
das ist eigentlich der Anstand den ich
unter Demokraten noch erwarte dass man
gratuliert wir haben jetzt den ganzen
Vormittag hier den Bundesvorstand der
CDU verfolgt mit dem auch was dort
gesprochen wurde da gab es mehrere Sätze
in Richtung Olaf Scholz zum einen Olaf
Scholz ist nicht der König also die
Anspielung darauf dass Olaf Scholz am
Ende auch nicht Kanzler werden könnte
was passiert da gerade bei der Union
also erstmal finde ich sehr ganz
spannend dass man wieder jeden Satz
nachlesen kann der dort im Präsidium mit
Parteivorstand gesprochen wird wir
hatten auch beide Gremien heute das war
wir wussten auch ein bisschen was von
der ist ja aber da sind diese Zitate
nicht also das ist ja vielleicht auch
ein Signal an FTP und grün also wie will
man mit den Verhandlung führen
vertrauensvoll wenn alles sofort hier an
ein Bild durchgestochen wird also das
erschüttert ja glaube ich schon das
Vertrauen ich verstehe natürlich dass
das hier freut aber man hat ja bei
Jamaika damals gesehen wie man
Verhandlung noch katastrophal führen
kann und die Union ist in einem
katastrophalen Zustand aber das was doch
gerade passiert ist dass in Frage
gestellt wird dass Olaf Scholz der
Gewinner des gestrigen Abends ist mit
der SPD so und und noch mal das ist ein
deutliches Ergebnis wir liegen deutlich
vorne es ist normal bisher in den Wahlen
immer gewesen dass die Partei die als
Sieger vom Platz geht dass die dann auch
die Gespräche führt und deswegen haben
wir heute im Präsidium im Parteivorstand
gesagt wir werden jetzt Gespräche führen
mit den Grünen mit der FDP was sagen
bekommen
wir haben ja auch in NRW koaliert und
heute will er Annalena baerbock anrufen
was machen Sie denn wenn Christian
Lindner und die Grünen sagen ja Armin
Laschet ist vor zweiter wir machen es
lieber mit dem das werden die nicht tun
also da bin ich mir ganz sicher dass die
Grünen und die Grünen und die FDP wissen
dass wir jetzt mit der SPD ein Gespräch
führen werden dass man auslotet an
welchen Stellen passt es zusammen wo
sind vielleicht Differenzen aber es geht
doch eine große Verantwortung die man
gemeinsam hat jetzt eine stabile
Regierung zu bilden die großen
Zukunftsaufgaben anzupacken und ganz
ehrlich ich meine Armin Laschet traut
sich nicht mal nach dem Fraktionsvorsitz
zu greifen also eigentlich wäre es doch
jetzt an ihm zu sagen er will jetzt der
starke Mann in der Union sein
Vorsitzender der CDU aber jetzt auch zu
sagen wenn er nicht mehr
Ministerpräsident in Nordrhein-Westfalen
ist ist doch der automatische Schritt
dass man nach dem Fraktionsvorsitz
greift aber nicht mal die Kraft hat er
gerade und trotzdem
ob FDP und Grüne sich nicht in diesen
Tagen auch mal fragen mit wem redet man
eigentlich in der Union wer hat
eigentlich das sagen wer bestimmt
eigentlich den Kurs aber kommt der
Unterstützung alle im Bundesvorstand
heute haben gesagt ja wir wollen Jamaika
regieren ist besser wir wollen nicht in
die Opposition ist ja nicht so dass die
CDU jetzt angefangen hätte Armin Laschet
irgendwie zu Mäuschen ja aber da lese
ich auch Zwischentöne also ich lese ja
auch die die sagen regieren es jetzt
nicht das wichtigste wir müssen erstmal
das Ergebnis aufarbeiten es gibt Kritik
an Armin Laschet ich habe Kretschmer
gelesen der auch sehr deutlich das in
Frage stellt also da gibt es schon
unterschiedliche Töne und jetzt warten
wir mal ab wie denn auch die
fraktionsgreme in der Union laufen die
haben einiges aufzuarbeiten also der
Balken ging bis tief in den Keller das
ist ein historisch schlechtes
Wahlergebnis das Junioren da eingefahren
hat und anscheinend tut Armin Laschet so
als ob da nichts passiert wäre
wenn man nicht mehr über einen Laschet
sondern über sie das Kanzleramt haben
sie ja auch noch nicht sicher und da
Armin Laschet sich offen
anbietet natürlich für die
Jamaika-Koalition haben die FDP und die
Grünen natürlich ein Pfund in der
Hinterhand wenn es jetzt in die
Entwicklung geht um eine Ampelkoalition
und werden Ihnen einiges abverlangen
können
Spitzensteuersatz und so weiter und so
fort wo sind da rote Linien oder geht es
ihnen auch nur um die Idee das ist das
was Robert Habeck er sagt wir müssen
eine neue Idee für Deutschland haben und
ansonsten pragmatisch sein das ist schon
historische Phase gerade Merkel gehört
auf nach 16 Jahren es gibt jetzt große
Zukunftsaufgaben die eine künftige
Regierung anpacken muss und es geht
jetzt überhaupt nicht darum öffentlich
irgendwelche Routen Linien zu ziehen
oder sagen das sind die Grenzen über die
wir nicht rüber gehen wir müssen jetzt
ausloten ob Grüne und FDP sagen ja wir
sind bereit gemeinsam Verantwortung zu
übernehmen Staatsmodernisierung das
Thema Europa Digitalisierung auch die
große Frage des Klimaschutzes sind wir
drei Parteien bereit jetzt zu sagen es
muss richtig angepackt werden und wir
müssen jetzt substantiell in den
nächsten Fähren vorankommen und dann
muss das eine Regierung sein die zum
Beispiel anders geprägt ist als die
schwarz-gelbe Regierung 2009 wo ja vom
ersten dann man sich die Butter auf den
Boden nicht gegönnt hat wo die FDP am
Ende der Legislatur hier rausgeflogen
ist aus dem Parlament gegeneinander
gegangen ist und deswegen geht es auch
um 9 Uhr einen neuen Stil des Regierens
es geht um ein neues Ziel des verhandeln
deutlich gemacht er hat gesagt es muss
jetzt ein Stil sein bei dem alle drei
auch ganz klar deutlich machen wir
können uns auch vorstellen dass wir in
der Konstellation wiedergewählt genau
und vor allem der FDP werden sie
natürlich auch Entgegenkommen müssen
Robert Habeck hat das vorhin gesagt er
hat gesagt die Partei die das Lager
wechseln muss also die FDP hat die
größere Zumutung zu tragen und eine
Ampel kann nicht Rot-Grün sein und ein
bisschen gelber Kit um dann am Ende eine
Mehrheit zu bekommen vor allem der FDP
werden Sie also Entgegenkommen müssen
und da gibt es natürlich die größten
Unterschiede aber es gibt auch viele
Gemeinsamkeiten noch mal Digitalisierung
Staatsmodernisierung der
gesellschaftliche Aufbruch der in diesem
Land jetzt wieder stattfinden kann den
die Union ja an vielen Stellen blockiert
hat das sind alles Dinge wo ich sage
lasst uns erstmal über gemeinsam
Möglichkeiten reden lass uns davon reden
wie die Gesellschaft aussehen soll in
die wir in die wir wollen und was wir
für große Ziele haben und dann haben Sie
Recht denn wenn man die Wahlprogramme
nebeneinander legt da gibt es
Unterschiede da gibt es Sachen wo wir
uns sicherlich hart streiten werden noch
in Verhandlungen aber das werden wir
intern tun und nicht öffentlich jetzt
gab es mehrere Angriffe heute im
Bundesvorstand gegen Olaf Scholz Thomas
Strobel hat gesagt Olaf Scholz ist kein
Kassenschlager was ihre Antwort
er ist der Kanzlerkandidat der jüngsten
Beliebtheitswerte hat der mit seiner
Partei das beste Ergebnis eingefahren
hat und ich glaube viele in der Union
wir hätten lieber einen anderen gehabt
als Armin Laschet dann der Vorwurf er
ist kein ostversteher das hat Armin
Laschet auch gesagt also Olaf Scholz hat
gestern in Ostdeutschland ein Wahlkreis
direkt gewonnen und wenn man auf die
Landkarte guckt dann sieht man die SPD
hat in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern in
Brandenburg in Thüringen in
Sachsen-Anhalt viele Wahlkreise gewonnen
und das haben wir getan auch durch ein
Kanzlerkandidaten Olaf schon und was
soll uns das sagen das Armin Laschet
findet noch mal die Frage dass Olaf
Scholz kein König ist was ist Olaf
Scholz für Sie ich will gar nicht dass
der König ist ich will dass er gewählter
Kanzler dieses Landes ist wir sind in
der demokratischen Wahl angetreten es
ist ja die Union die die letzten Wochen
immer so ein bisschen getan hat ihn
alles gehört also diese dieser Vorwurf
auf der erbschleicherei also das zeigt
das Verständnis der Union die gehören
die denken den gehört das Land aber
sowas wie König kommt uns gar nicht über
die Lippen wir wollen das Olaf Scholz
der nächste Kanzler ist und das sind
alles verzweifelte Attacken von einem
Flasche der gerade um sein Überleben um
sein politisches Überleben kämpft das
kann ich nachvollziehen aber das ist
nicht seriös und ich bin gespannt wie
lange die Union das mitmacht man muss
auch zeigen dass man Lust hat zu
regieren und nicht das als alles
freudlos ist hat er vorhin auch gesagt
in der Pressekonferenz ich glaube wer
Olaf Scholz in diesen Tagen erlebt der
sieht der hat Lust der hat große Lust
die Veränderung in diesem Land
voranzubringen aber es geht um
Seriosität es geht darum ist jetzt auch
ernsthaft zu machen und nochmal Armin
Laschet ist ein bisschen außer Rand und
Band wer Olaf Scholz in diesen Tagen
erlebt der sieht der ist vorbereitet der
weiß welche großen Aufgaben vor ihm
liegen und die Partei steht hinter ihm
Herr klingt mal viele Stöhnen natürlich
auch oh Gott so viele Gespräche ist es
alles so komplex man kommt nicht auf
einen Nenner wie lange glauben Sie
realistisch gesehen wird es dauern bis
eine Regierung zustande kommt also jetzt
war gestern die Wahl jetzt haben alle
mal ein bisschen gefeiert bei uns
zumindest in der Partei wir haben uns
heute in den Gremien gesagt ich soll
jetzt schnell sein dass man zusammen
kommt ein schnelles Gespräch mit den
Grünen ein schnelles Gespräch mit der F
okay dann werden wir das Bewerten und
das muss jetzt in den nächsten Tagen
stattfinden das heißt bis Weihnachten
müssen wir nicht warten na bis
Weihnachten muss man sowieso nicht
warten mit den Gesprächen aber selbst
wenn es dann darum geht und das hoffe
ich mal dass wir eine gemeinsame
Regierung bilden dann wollen wir das
schnell tun erwarten sie dass die
Kanzler noch eine Ansprache halten wird
eine Weihnachtsansprache oder also mein
Ansporn ist dass wir schneller sind als
dass die Kanzlerin noch arbeiten muss
Weihnachten
das klingt bald vielen Dank für den
Besuch hier im Studio sehr gerne danke
schön danke
[Musik]